so I suck I'm serious  I suck at a lot of things not a good  reader I can't pronounce crap  um I'm not that educated uh you know I  bite my nails I do a lot of things wrong  you know I live in the moment too much  sometimes I forget about outside stuff  as a matter of fact I probably sit here  for the next six years and talk about  things I suck but I don't I focus on  what I'm good at and I talk about what  I'm good at which is mine for example  and you know so I think a lot more  people need to stop worrying about what  they suck at don't worry about what  they're good at I think a lot of people  come to me and say well I can't do video  like you oh my god Brian so right if  that's what you're good at people  embracing what they rock at and stop  worrying about what they suck at is the  key to victory  think about it